First off, keep their graphics as jpegs.
These are raster images they're taking,
so keep them saved in a raster format.
For the second question,
considering your users
are accessing your site on mobile.
It's actually a good idea to
inline these images if you can.
Inlining reduces the number of
requests the browser has to make.
And requests are one of the major
contributors to laggy or
unperformant websites on mobile.
Requests add round trips.
And round trips are one of the biggest
factors for slow websites on mobile.
But, with that being
said in the next lesson,
you'll see how inlining images can
limit your responsive options.
So, in the end an external file
still might be the way to go.
Either answer is correct.